people's history of the United States
1492 to the present fortunate son
working on the chain gang shaken off the
dead hand of history all of those topics
and more please welcome a history of
America a conversation with Howard Zinn
and Walter Mosley so here we are huh
it's very funny you know like they kind
of put us out on stage and we met
backstage they didn't tell us what to do
no no but that's maybe that's good huh
yeah we don't like to follow orders
anyway Joey that's right I don't
anything I know that so anyway so I'm
gonna start I'm gonna ask you a question
there's something I've been working on
lately and it actually started in this
room I was giving a talk I don't know
like maybe eight years ago saw datoria
man and I started talking about the vote
and a woman in the audience said very
angrily to me that man I heard enough
about the vote when we going to do
something you know and I thought wow you
know she's right and and and so I've
been thinking lately I've been thinking
about well there's two things I mean
I've been thinking about starting a
website where people can download
software in order to identify themselves
as a special interest group and then to
find other people who agree with their
interests and then take that from the
virtual world to the real world the
reason that I want to do it and I want
to see how what you think about this is
it's my understanding that rather than
living in a democracy by default we're
living in a mostly benevolent oligarchy
hmm what do you think mostly been I
don't know how we never liked it
no but no this business of the vote is
really important because we live in a
culture and you can see this by
what television emphasizes what the
newspapers emphasize everything is built
around the vote everything is built
around who is going to be the next
president because we all learn as we're
growing up in this country the really
the most important thing is who is
president and who is in Congress and
what we should have learned by now if we
really learn history or if we just
looked around or thought about it is
that the President Congress the Supreme
Court they get all the attention but the
fact is we cannot depend on them to
bring about a state of justice and
equality in this country it is up to us
that's why what you're saying about the
Internet and bringing people together
grassroots groups making connections I
mean that's democracy right but you know
you've got a junior high school and they
teach you what democracy is and they
they put on the board the three branches
of government and they talk to you about
checks and balances and no that's not
democracy I mean it's one kind of very
bureaucratic like wing of democracy
right yeah well it's you know democracy
is what people do for themselves and if
you look through history what you find
is that where we've had really serious
problems to solve
they haven't been solved by the
President or by Congress or by the
Supreme Court the President and Congress
of spring' what they react to the social
movements and that exist in the country
and so slavery was not simply abolished
because Abraham Lincoln issued the
Emancipation Proclamation that ran the
his Emancipation Proclamation came after
30 years of grassroots agitation by
black people and some white people know
who were creating a great movement and
and we've seen that more recently right
we couldn't depend on
even the so-called liberal presidents
Johnson Kennedy to enforce the 14th and
15th amendments now what happened black
people had to go out in the streets and
all over the south and risk their lives
in order to make sure that the 14th and
15th amendments were finally enforced
yeah so you know the idea of they've
bamboozled Osment with the idea of you
know the voting is the most important
thing we can do and it's it's like one
thing that you do one day every four
years or so
and and and then that there's a there's
a lot more to do in between and there's
a lot more to understand but but one of
the one of the things at least for me
that that that's so confusing
it's a lot of people say what they'll
come to me and they'll say well people
don't know this people don't know that
their vote doesn't count or people don't
know that that they're being bamboozled
that they're they're being fooled but it
seems to me like people do know it seems
to me that most people I talk to and I'm
not talking about in New York you know
because that's that can get very strange
but but even like you know like I'll be
in the Midwest and I'll be talking you
know to some you know old guy out there
and they'll be saying
they'll be explained to me how their
medical insurance isn't working how
their retirement isn't working how their
children are making the exact same
salary that they were making 20 years
ago and and so knowledge alone doesn't
seem to create enough of an impetus to
change them yeah I think you're right
about people knowing you know well you
can tell that people know the inadequacy
of voting by the fact that half the
people in the country don't vote in
presidential elections why don't they
vote because they I think don't believe
that the voting is going to mean
anything and even 50% of people who do
vote well we know there's they vote
without enthusiasm because what choice
do they have you know and you know I
once saw a bumper sticker and said
if God hasn't had intended us to vote he
would have given us candidates so your
people know there's people know a lot
you see it's amazing it's amazing that
people know as much as they do
considering the fact that the the media
television newspapers do their best to
keep people ignorant and and and our
educational system doesn't do a lot to
give people a real history and yet
people you know are intelligent and have
come but the question is it and this is
a question you raised I think they know
these things and yet very often that
knowledge isn't transformed into action
and I think the reason for that is that
people very often don't know their own
power and this is where history they
feel helpless they know these things but
you don't know what to do about it
and it's only at certain points in
history that people learn how much power
they have you know it's well I'm
thinking of the South you know where I
lived with my family for years of the
movement you know late 50s and early 60s
south and black people knew what their
lives were like but it took a while for
them to transform that knowledge into
his fantastic movement and and and and
that movement was comprised very greatly
of young people right good to others and
that you know because I'm one of
problems I have today I'll talk to I'll
talk to somebody and I'll say I'll make
a suggestion I'll say why don't you get
this young woman or this young guy to
lead your organization and say well they
only 27 I said well you know that's how
Martin Luther King was when they did the
boycott yeah well he was different they
don't make people like him anymore
you know there's that kind of but but
that's a self-defeating notion right
like if and and and and that that
becomes a part of it and another thing
like another step beyond that I think
it's connected to that I'll say somebody
said well who you vote for and I said
well you know who I vote for it doesn't
matter how I vote and how identify
myself matters and then they don't hear
that and they say why like Barack Obama
let's say you know where Hillary Clinton
or Rudy Giuliani I don't know who they
say but they say somebody and and I said
they say let's let's say they say Brock
and I say yes I like him and I said well
do you know him
right and they well yeah I know what he
stands for I said whoa you thought you
knew a Clinton stand for right and you
know I know he lived in Harlem and
everything but you thought you knew that
and you were wrong and and you
understand I'm trying to say this as a
question of of there's some knowledge
that we that we believe that we have
that we don't really have mmm I like
people have like you know Barack Obama
and Hillary Clinton and all of their
like rock stars but we don't know them
and you know you were talking about the
young people Walter and and what I find
is I talk a lot and probably you do too
high school kids these high school kids
very often way ahead of the adults who
write for the New York Times or or who
are the anchors on television they have
certain instincts about things and and
wonder one of the reasons that all these
books around here Harry
you put on this for young people yeah I
didn't you put them there thanks so much
my fault but it's my father wrote them
no but one of the reasons for writing
for young people is because young people
do not get a kind of history that
empowers them yeah the young people they
get the heroes they get are the
presidents and the industrialist and the
military heroes especially the military
heroes to prepare these young people for
the next recruiting officer who comes
into high school but no
we want young people to have as their
heroes the people in the anti-slavery
movement the people who led working
people that Louisville organizes the
Cesar Chavez the boycott is we want them
to to learn that about the anti-war
people about the those who protested our
various Wars we want them to learn about
socialists and anarchists in this
centers the kind of people you don't
read about in history like like Thomas
Paine who somehow gets left out of
history but it's such an important
figure it says I'm a revolutionary not a
guy who follows the rules absolutely so
we need new sets of heroes for young
people not to you not Christopher
Columbus and not Theodora
and not andrew jackson we need Fannie
Lou Hamer and blah blah sirs I mean the
right Bob Moses or the left but but but
but part of the problem is of course I
mean or what would seem it seems to me
the a promise that you came up in a time
and and you were very politically active
in a time not that you aren't still
politically active but but talking about
those earlier days where young people
were a part of the movement young people
were at least to some degree respected
young people were allowed or in some way
made their own way along with their
elders to kind of pull us along to push
us further and that's really not true
today it's very you know it's really not
true a lot even like in places like the
black community where young people seem
to be denigrated a lot you know well I
won't speak for the black community you
won't
I know white people speak for the black
community all the time so why should I
write but no I okay I won't but but I
see when I go to anti-war vigils and
anti-war demonstrations or when a few
years ago I went to one of these great
demonstrations of people who were
demonstrating for rights of immigrants a
lot of Latino people but other people I
see a lot of young people in these
demonstrations right there I think that
there is a
a lot of odd activity yeah but at the
top there's a lot of people who kind of
had stant
keeping their positions I won't name
anybody cuz you know I might be in
trouble but but I think that there are a
lot of people who Maine who maintain
their position and at the same time I
think this is not necessarily historical
but it's it's it's one of the ways I
think that you go about thinking about
history like I'll uh I'll be talking to
somebody and they'll start talking about
hip hop people and they'll say and
they'll say it's hip hop's
the call hip hop caused Don Imus to say
bad things about black basketball
players and and I'm sayin so you mean
it's hip hop's problem that there's
racism and they they go yeah well no but
and then and then and then the US and I
and I and I I always say there's some
people interview me in the interviews
never make it into the news they never
making the newspapers but I said well
the reason that that people are using
this language is the prisons hip-hop
that the whole that whole it's a it's
another kind of protest music movement
instead of coming out of slavery it's
coming out of the prisons it's it's
language it's thoughts and ideas
self-deprecation set cetera that come
out of prison and I say to people I said
if you want people to stop using this
language you should do something about
the prisons but this becomes too big a
thing they say oh no I just want them to
stop using the language mmm they just
just say it stop saying [ __ ] and hos
not be fine you know and you know well
if I'm glad you brought up prisons
because we have in this country now over
2 million people in prisons I mean this
is the largest rate of incarceration of
any place in the world yeah and a lot of
really bad places in the world and so
when you think of the fact that some
people are offended when you say that
you know this this isn't the Great
Society that we grew up thinking we were
there are many signs that were not the
greatest society we have troops in a
hundred different countries in the world
military bases we are selling arms to
countries all over the world
we have 40 million people have health
care and we have two million people in
prison yeah there's something sick about
a society that has two million people in
prison and the two million people
present have something to do with wealth
and poverty and with the way the wealth
of this country is being squandered into
military ventures and given to the
super-rich and the result of this gap
between rich and poor is you get all
these people in prison and this is
another thing which you know this is
just kind of one of my personal things
I'm looking at people in prison and and
you look at a town let's say some a
little town sets a white town and the
Midwest and they say we're not doing so
well so we'll build a prison they want
us developers will build a prison and
they built a prison and they put like
you know 7,000 people in the prison most
of whom were people of color you know or
poor white people are just crazy and
they have them in prison you know cuz
Reagan you know close to all the mental
institutions you know and and anyway so
so that so we have all these people in
prison but and the last time the census
counted there was like 5,000 people now
this time the census come around and
they say there's 12,000 people and they
get all the benefits they get that they
could get the tax benefits they they get
the the electoral benefits in in their
own own area and also nationally but
still they won't let people in prison
vote
well it's interesting here that's they
are proud that's right there are
millions of votes that are uncounted
yeah and then now why shouldn't
prisoners have a right to vote the human
being except they're an American
American human being and not only that
they're smart and they have a lot of
time to think about it everyone is
currently yeah they read they read a lot
of books you know yeah and and yeah they
should be voting I mean one of the one
of the shameful thing is about the
election of 2000 and that's true of all
of his elections but we saw it
especially 2000 all his people were not
allowed to vote in Florida right
thousands and thousands of people are
not allowed to vote in Flour
because of their prison records right of
course in some cases it was even faked
their prison records but they were gonna
go to flats where they were they thought
they might go to prison someday so I
shouldn't vote so black you live in
Miami you going to prison
yeah and no I I correspond with several
you probably do too because you know
includes me and everything you know I
don't do anything good no good I just
know you do anything because I'm sure
that people read your books in prison
and they write to you right and you
write back so correspond with people in
prison and I very often have a feeling
that any one of these prisoners that I
write to would make a better president
than the one we have in the White House
you see really and and here they are
absolutely there's no question about
that and and and and your number I mean
I don't want to let correct you because
you know your Howards End so it's hard
you know I want to correct you but the
number two million is a way low number
right it's really like six million
there's like the two million that are
coming back there's the two million or
three million that are out who may be
going back or may not be going back and
a great many of them can't vote and a
great many of them are stigmatized and
and like you know if you can't vote in
America you don't have the right to vote
in America that's yeah that means it's
like taking away your citizenship it's
like and it's certainly taking away the
power of all these poor and community
and communities of color who have no no
possibility for representation or
thought and it's hard I can't even talk
on in liberals I get on liberal stations
and they they're okay when I say people
who come out of prison can vote but when
I say prisoners can float they go they
said what that's that's too much mister
Muslim that's too much and and I go why
so well I don't want a rapist vote it
I'm saying you think everybody in prison
is a rapist as well or murderer what
about the people who write bad checks
why can't they vote you know I mean it's
really that people write bad checks are
pretty smart yeah
they better not I can't do I try they
would make good choices yeah that's
definitely I said well Howard's
yeah 1 million dollars by the way weld I
know I said this we just met today
thankfully for the first time we should
have met a long time ago I couldn't have
five years old but we just met today and
but I've been reading Walter Mosley's
books for years and you know I'm you
don't write history books but the people
you write about are the people who are
left out in history Yeah right the
people the people on the street the
people you know they you know easy wrong
if a person who represents a whole
culture and he has to be listened to he
should be listened to if people listen
to him you know we might have a
different country in a different world
well thank you I mean thank you very
much it is it is true that that it's
hard to it's hard to find in any kind of
like you know central system and our
government people who pay attention to
everyday people like you know I think
that that your history of course you
know talks about well how everyday
people experienced history how all those
people who are ignored experienced
history and you know also bring out the
lies of history so any because like
women couldn't vote until 1920 I mean
like so were they living in a democracy
and you know in America all this time
and and but it's really it's very
difficult it's difficult it's not
difficult to do I think cuz I think you
and and and myself also naturally think
about working people and working-class
people in and everyday people but it's
hard to get that you know there's not it
doesn't seem sexy I mean I think one of
the problems it doesn't seem sexy and
also it doesn't support the super-rich
as you say I not supposed to mention the
super-rich but the what I was thinking
about say is that when you know as you
were talking and as I was talking I was
thinking what are we doing we're being
very critical right and we're saying we
don't really have a democracy and you
know I mean right you called it an old
adding a little bit Netherlands but but
people very often people listening to us
like what we're not a democracy you know
why are you putting us down America is
the greatest country in the world you
hear this again and again you mustn't
criticize because we are the greatest
country in the world because everybody
pledges allegiance to the flag by the
time you know that one foot high and
they singing a song about liberty and
justice for all and all of that and so
when they hear somebody say you know
we're not really a democracy or the
their few very very powerful rich people
who are at the top in a control Society
they think you're being unpatriotic yeah
and they use that word unpatriotic and
they forget what patriotism really is
the patriotism is love of your country
it's not love of your government there's
a difference between the government and
the country yeah I don't have to love
George Bush Wow come to think of it you
don't that's really good I like that and
you know it so you see the television
cameras focus on young men in uniform
going off to Iraq and sometimes they'll
say yeah and tell me young man why why
did you enlist and he'll or young woman
listen well because I believe I owe
something to my country I want to fight
for my country
they've been deluded they're not going
to fight for their country they're gonna
fight for Bush and Cheney and
Halliburton they're gonna fight for the
corporations that may crop it out of war
you know the country doesn't need war
the country doesn't need to spend this
huge huge sums of money trillions of
dollars on or the country needs to take
care of people here and to take care of
people elsewhere
that's the country and and I think when
the government acts against the
interests of the country we should tear
it down I was hoping he would say
something
no no no it should be Tory I mean I I
love it that that was cindy sheehan
right has said that that she's that you
know Pelosi doesn't vote to try to
impeach bush that she's gonna run
against her that's democracy say you're
not doing what I want so I'm gonna run
against you and see if the people agree
with me or if the people agree with you
and in San Francisco I'm sure they're
gonna agree with with you know she and
so that would be really great and I
think that to say that we need to tear
the government down is not a bad thing
you know the government because the
government doesn't represent us well you
know when you say tear the government
down I mean the writers of the
Declaration of Independence didn't use
those exact words but they said
basically the same thing because in the
Declaration of Independence which by the
way the leaders of our government really
don't want us to read very carefully but
their Declaration of Independence says
that when governments become destructive
of the rights of equality and life
liberty the pursuit of happiness become
destructive of those it is the right of
the people to alter or abolish the
government and you know and certainly
right now it is our right to impeach the
president and vice president Olivia
right now
and I a there's Emily this there's no
question that that we have the right and
that we should but there's also no
question that we feel helpless even
though we and not just two people in
this audience but we are in the majority
which is it is an interesting moment how
democracy has turned in our oligarchy
pretending it's democracy because it
allows us to vote for either the
Democrat or the Republican which is like
a crazy notion you know say those are my
two choices
you know I'm looking at these people I
said there's all kinds of people I know
it's like you say I know people on my
block who would be a better president
than anybody running you know it's like
you know and it's like and they might
not be the best president and I think
it's it's really you know and one of my
one of my issues is getting people to
know it because you know in this thing
that I want to do downloading the thing
to so people can start into interest
groups you know I'm thinking well listen
it doesn't matter you know like if
you're a black nationalist or you're in
the Aryan Brotherhood or you like you
know it doesn't matter what kind of
religion you are or if you're
conservative or liberal or radical or
whatever reactionary I think everybody
in America wants medical care a living
wage a place to live and the ability to
age with dignity I think everybody I
mean I don't know anybody who would say
I don't want dad I don't want medical
care man you know well you think I am
some kind of well yeah so it seems to me
that democracy naturally would lead to
work giving those things and for some
reason it's leading away from it well we
may be at you know at that point in
history where the American colonists
were on the eve of the American
Revolution I'm serious about that right
and and that is that they were the point
where the people in charge the people
who were the officials of the British
government were not taking care of
people's knees in fact were oppressing
them or were taxing them and and what
did they do they couldn't depend on
these institutions
and so they created the grassroots
movements that had Committees of
Correspondence and and these committees
were meeting all over the the country
and alt and the consulate here's a
pamphlet here is that the poets the
writers Tom Haines yeah you know and and
it seems to me if the leaders of
Congress the Democrats who are now it
even with a slim majority have a
majority if they are not willing to act
on impeachment yeah which is which is
what we really need now because we don't
want to wait for the next election we
want to get get rid of the people in the
White House right now you see yeah and
if if the Democrats are not going to do
it then we need something like the
Committees of Correspondence that is we
need community groups town meetings and
to take place neighborhood meetings take
place all over the country with people
demanding impeachment yeah
and you know to create a national
movement which then will might scare
Congress into acting because Congress is
easily scared well but I mean one of the
one of the things as we're looking at
the Democratic history you could say not
very far I mean that real history our
history that we can remember but still
it happened a while ago at one time the
Democrats are supported by labor and the
Republicans were supported by the
super-rich okay you know I mean that's
not perfect but it's okay you know I
mean at least it's two different sides
but you know Reagan pretty much got rid
of the unions the unions are very very
small amount of Americans today American
workers are unionized and most of them
are retired then because of that the
Democrats and Republicans are supported
by the same group of people right I mean
so like the Democrats are sitting there
in office they're not helping us but
there's a reason they're not helping us
is because you know Halliburton doesn't
just give to to the Republicans you know
a Mobil Oil and Bank of America and and
Pfizer and you know I mean in like
Walmart and all these other people they
don't just give to the Republicans they
give the Democrats to their
all owned by the same people you know I
once I once figured out it when the
Republicans have a fundraising dinner
they will charge four hundred thousand
dollars for somebody to attend the
fundraising dinner Democrats are
different they will only charge three
hundred thousand dollars you know
they're liberals yeah that they're
liberals yeah and and what's interesting
to me is that when they pass the
military budget everybody
democrat and republican vote for the
military budget we just passed the
largest military budget in history over
five hundred billion dollars
unanimously voted by both Republicans
and Democrats and this is this this is
shocking is that you know no sorry a
couple people voted against it in there
well not on the not actually on the
military budget but there are a couple
of good people in Congress yeah who have
voted against war resolutions or voted
against the Patriot Act I mean I think
of Barbara Lee in California he's
wonderful right you know yeah right
after 9/11 and they passed the
resolution giving Bush the authority to
go to war
Bobby Lee was the only person in
Congress to speak up against that that
was courage and a few people now in
Congress speaking up John Lewis I heard
John Lewis who comes out of that
movement in the South John Lewis
delivered impassioned speech on the
floor of the house calling for the
withdrawal of our troops from Iraq
because it got no coverage yeah got no
coverage on the press and it wasn't
picked up by you know the other people
of the other Democrats in Congress so
there you know there are few people Minh
and then just for a moment the negative
space the the positive space that saves
the United States the borders of the
United States and the negative space is
international policy I mean I don't know
very many people in America who know
anything about the theory behind our
foreign policy it leads me to think that
corporations make up completely our
foreign policy am I wrong about that
well I think you're like ninety eight
percent right
because I never want to conceal
something about oh okay I never want to
concede that anybody is 100% right so no
that's good but I'm gonna take your
class yeah but it's interesting that
when they teach courses and there's one
I know about because I was in
departments of political science so they
taught courses in international
relations do all sorts of courses in
international relations and in those
courses in international relations there
was virtually nothing about the role of
rich corporations in influencing and
directing foreign policy but I mean
there's no question about it that our
foreign policy and this is where history
comes in handy you go way back the
military ventures of the United States
the interventions of the United States
have always had an economic motive
behind them with the Mexican War in 1846
the motive was the land with the
spanish-american war in 1898 the motive
was the raw materials of Cuba same thing
true with the Philippines and with the
Vietnam War there were economic motives
the tin rubber oil in Southeast Asia and
of course right now with Iraq the
economic motive is clear although they
want to talk about it
oil they talk about democracy or build
it you know which is nonsense
imagine the Bush administration gonna
bring democracy to anybody I mean that
well they should bring it here first I
mean yeah I'd like to have something
yeah at least a little of it yes like my
new Harry Potter book you know I've been
waiting online with something round my
wrists in with some democracy please
yeah you know we're sitting in Harlem
you know and we're just in an audience
at Harlem and so like Anna and I know
you don't speak for Bucky but I'm gonna
put you on the spot with a what the
question because you know it's it's
something that I've been thinking about
lately and I began to bring it up we're
talking about young people you know
because young people in America think a
lot differently at this moment at this
juncture than than their previous
generations and and they're they're
thinking new ways and going in new ways
black people like for instance if you're
in film anybody was in film knows that
if you if make a black make a feel
even if there's all black people had
never called black phone cuz you're not
gonna sell that film in Europe you're
not gonna sell that film in Asia and
you're not gonna sell that film in South
America there's a there's a notion about
black people that we've become even
though at one point we were leading the
world fighting for freedom now it's
become a kind of we're seen as kind of
parochial in a way on an international
level and a lot internally a lot of
internal and and I'm one and I believe
you know I when I was in my house
watching the planes crash in the World
Trade Center you know some years ago and
and and I and after after I got off the
phone I mean after I got you know for
the next couple three four months people
called me and maybe 2,000 people called
me or I called them half of them were
black people half of them were were
white people the one thing that all
black people had in common was none of
them were surprised about the attacks I
didn't talk to one black person not one
I haven't since that I've talked to one
but that was the only one then who was
shocked by the attack that other people
would hate us so much that they would
attack they didn't necessarily like it
they might have been afraid they might
have been patriotic they might have
joined the army I don't know what they
did but they weren't surprised they said
well yeah you know you had to know that
was gonna happen then they try to blow
it up just a few years before that you
don't you know and of course you say
yeah that that's true you think that
somebody would think about that but they
were still surprised and and I'm
wondering especially in a city in Harlem
addressing a primarily black audience
here that is there a way that that we
have to refigure ourselves in order to
deal with this change in world
you know it's interesting that black
people you know as you suggested in the
reaction to 9/11 black people have
generally been more perceptive about the
United States and what is doing in the
world what is doing to the world you
know for obvious reasons because the
whatever the United States has been
doing to the world whether we were
sending Marines into Central America are
sending armies into Southeast Asia and
Alan
well whatever the reasons the United
States was always saying we're doing
this for democracy
I want to drift and black people in this
country you know would you know I want
to do you know they would laugh at this
you're doing this for democracy right
now and so in fact when they take calls
or you know anti-war attitudes it's
always clear the largest anti-war
attitudes are always among the black
population they know so the other ones
we should talk to first if we want to
find out what's going on but I think
they have a better connection with the
rest of the world them are honest about
who we are and what we are and I think
all the reason for talking to young
people and the reason for giving young
people a different kind of history you
know is that we should be honest with
young people then we often they think
young people oh well they need fairy
tales they don't you know we should
shield them from the reality of what we
have done in the world though we
shouldn't shield them we shouldn't
protect them we have to be honest if we
want to face ourselves and it's been
easier for black people to be honest
about what we've done we see the real
America I mean it's like and it's pretty
easy when say no you can't vote you know
and no you you can't have this job no
you can't be in this place so you know I
mean it happens again and again over and
over again and and it becomes problem
even in the most even the most liberal
institutions you find a whole bunch of
white people up in there you know and
you saying oh wow
but it's at the same time now and really
I'm setting this up for the audience and
I need you to agree with it because I
know you'll be uncomfortable agreeing
with it nobody knows how to act like a
white person better than black people I
mean
you know I mean because you studied
you've studied us we here we studied you
our whole lives I've been watching you
man I got that you know it's like it's
and so here we are extremely powerful in
our knowledge but unable it seems to me
that mean for instance we talk about
black people voting black people in
prison voting every black person in
America should tell the next candidate
if we don't have our black men and women
in prison voting we ain't gon vote for
you we shouldn't be Democrats or
Republicans we should have the interest
of our own people in mind and we don't
Ruby Dee who was on the stage with last
night was sitting in front of a giant
audience of black people and she said
she asked me who said do you know why
the movie beloved didn't work
everybody's looking at it and she said
cuz you didn't go to it on the first
week me and you know she was right about
90% of people in the room you know it's
like you know they went to see you know
die hard or whatever lose my you know I
didn't go see but there's all this power
that we have and there's all this
knowledge that we have but there's
something stopping that right but it's
interesting about power people don't
know their own power because the people
who seem to have power well I suppose
they don't just seem that power they do
have the power they have the power to
take our wealth they have the power to
send people to die overseas they have
the power and yet they're really not
all-powerful because their power depends
on everybody else's obedience exact if
people stopped obeying they would not
have power you know it you're talking
about it you know if if people went to
see beloved okay people have buying
power you know Cesar Chavez recognized
that we have the power of the boycott
I remember when when
Jesse Jackson announced that he might
start a boycott of Texaco because Texas
goes racial policies as soon as that was
announced in the press Texaco
immediately said oh we're changing right
the boycott is a very powerful thing the
boy if people use the boycott divine
power if young people refuse to go into
the military they depend on the military
for their wars they can't fight wars
without young people going to it but but
now can I this meant because this this
is one thing that seems very obvious to
me but nobody's I haven't really read it
but I don't it's not really President
Bush it's really president Cheney's
President Cheney Heather Cheney has done
a really brilliant thing he's he would
he he did you know he lives he supports
the super-rich he helps the super-rich
the super-rich and more more like you
know garnered their power
we have dollars they have euros you know
you know we have dollars they have yen's
you know I mean like it's like and and
so these made a whole bunch of the
underclass declared a war but didn't
declare a draft so no you don't I mean
the people are saying because you're
saying that people say they're going
because they're patriotic which is true
but you know my cynical side says you
know they also promised am I'm gonna
give you $50,000 I'm gonna give you an
education I'm gonna make sure that you
know your children will be you know
you're living in luxury and of course
they're not gonna get many of that yeah
you know I mean everybody I knew join
you know this then I'm still trying to
fight for that 10,000 they promised me
but they Daniel sent it yet but I'm
gonna figure it out yeah you know but
but the thing is is that there's no I
mean we should dig we've made a lower
class you know and and men and women can
join and so they can fill up the army
without a dress but they're having more
trouble doing it now you know the truth
the truth gets through it takes a while
for the truth to get past the media and
the power of the government but I'd says
proof that proof that
truth is getting through is the numbers
of people who more and more and more are
opposed to the war despite the fact that
they've been misled by the press in the
media mm-hmm and so there is a truth
that gets through and it gets through
over time and so they're having trouble
meeting their recurring quotas even with
all the money that they're offering all
the bonuses that they're offering well
they don't give the lies they're telling
right yeah yeah so that that's a good
sign it is except for if people got more
poor which it kind of is it's not
unlikely especially if you pay rent in
Manhattan how many people still do you
know but it's like the the that the idea
is that if you can make somebody hungry
enough if you get out of high school you
get out of college and you can't get a
job and then the army offers you
anything so at least they give me a
place to sleep
yeah sure yeah I mean yeah army I might
be able to go back and said we'll give
you a place to sleep and then you know
we know you're kind of frustrated so we
let you kill some people too you know I
mean yeah it's I mean it's a and I
understand your side you know I mean
you're very optimistic and I read your
that the thing is wrote in 2004 about
optimism and you know and I'm an
optimistic person I like it but but but
but there's a whole system against us
especially you know poor black people
poor Hispanic people and poor white
people they do exist you know that that
they there's there there's there there
doesn't seem to be a way out and still
this moment of of helplessness you know
invades and and you know and I know I
keep getting back to it but you know it
seems to me so important you know like
you know you ask because I ask people I
don't ask people why we're fighting Iraq
I just has who who are we fighting yeah
you know and it and they said well we
the enemy that's it yeah well but
they're our friends we've given them
democracy and we're killing them at the
same time I don't get it and you know
and and I think most people nobody
answers my question mmm when I asked
them who were fighting they said well we
point a gun at somebody and if he pulls
out a gun we know he's the enemy you
know I mean yeah
but look that's why we're here right
yeah that's why you and I are here
that's why these people are here that's
why there are more and more people in
this country who are learning and who
are getting into truth and problem is to
convert the knowledge that more and more
people are having is obvious that well
look how many people believe in bush
anymore in this country a tiny a
minority of people believe in in Bush
and Cheney anymore most people have
gotten wise to that problem is
converting this knowledge into action
but but but organizing organizing and
acting but the but the but the but most
people in America think the action is to
elect you know Hillary Clinton or Barack
Obama yeah well I mean there's a problem
you know they're not gonna I mean you
see that picture of Hillary Clinton you
remember that like three months ago
darris Hillary there's Barack and they
got 26 million dollars next to the
Hillary's name and 25 million you know
and it's not a bounty or anything it's
how much money somebody gave them and I
talked to people to say they said you
see how much money Barack got I said
well but they bought him with that money
right mmm and then look at me like no no
no what they bought him you know he you
know nobody gives you 25 million dollars
for nothing you know
so they okay so Bush can't hear any more
so you know but but if no even if there
is the Democrat the Democrat you like
you know let's say like the Democrat
everybody likes you al gore you know
gets you know elected president is that
really gonna make the difference
elections elections don't do it clean
social movements do it yeah and this is
what people have to learn no matter who
is elected president we've got to have a
People's Movement a race country and we
have to have the kinds of things that
happened in the 60s we have the people
all over the country are the kind of
things that happened in the south yeah
this look people in the south did not
have a president in the White House even
when it was Kennedy or Johnson they did
not have a president in White House who
was going to change things and people in
the south learn black people in south
learned
they had to do it themselves and they
created a movement which galvanized the
south and and we need a movement like
that in this country and and do you see
like right and for the audience and for
the you know of people watching this
place other way do you see a place to
grab on in order to begin this room
because you know you can see you know in
the south and the 50s and the 60s how
people identified with each other you
know pressed into neighborhoods being
being robbed of their rights and their
there of the and their what their wealth
and their ability to stuff like that
people today a lot don't feel that they
feel you know they you know I was like
to say the Americas religion is
capitalism you know which is why people
would never admit being poor you know
eighty percent of countries working
class and and eighty percent of the
country says they're middle class you
know you don't even understand it you
know say yeah because you know the
difference the difference between a
working class person middle class person
says Oh middle class person if they lose
their job they don't have to get another
job for about a year they can live at
the same level give to the same
charities go to the same clubs kiss stay
in the same schools a working-class
person they lose their job they got to
get another job in two weeks or their
whole life changes you know that's most
of America right you know and and and it
I I don't I don't but but people don't
they don't want to identify with that
they want to identify being middle class
and so they don't seem ready to move you
know we got a million black people in
prison to me in black people either
going in or coming out of prison we
don't have a movement about that well
it's time for a movement all right it's
time for a new movement and we've gone
through we've gone through other periods
in American history where it didn't seem
like anything was happening and when
things were going on yeah and movements
built up you know the room is build up
over time and you know in the 1830s the
movement against slavery was was tiny
and and then it grew and grew and you
have to have certain confidence you know
and in South in the 1950s and 1960s
it looked impossible mm-hmm I mean right
and the federal government wasn't doing
anything and the southern governments
were completely in a Polly some of
everything in the hands of white
supremacists so I think you have to
start somewhere you have to have the
faith that that if you start and do
something there's somebody else and then
the community will do something some of
the young the other side of the country
will do something and the you haven't
have the faith that if you act if you in
the smallest act of rebellion that at
some point you will be joined by others
I mean that's how things have happened
in this country historically it has
happened hasn't happened because of
Congress or the Supreme Court or the
president has happened you know a labor
movement was created and people went on
strike and people stopped the machinery
of Industry a movement took place in the
south and and people just galvanized the
country by what they were doing you know
wind obviously are in need of a new
national movement because this is a very
rich country the wealth has been
concentrated in a very small number of
hands and all desmond mmm and always has
been
that's right it's time to change that
and it's time to change the image of
america from a marauder in the world to
being a decent citizen in the world
which means remove our troops from other
countries right starting with Iraq but
from remove our troops from everywhere
and use the immense wealth of this
country to give everybody free health
care and whatever it is people need to
live a decent life and we can't depend
on Congress or the Supreme Court of the
President we can only depend on
ourselves and we have to start wherever
we are get together with your neighbors
get together in your community I mean
this is how this is how change is taking
place in history the civil rights
movement did
way the labor movement did it that way
the women's movement did it that way and
we're gonna have to do it today
ourselves we will have to organize we
didn't have to take action we're gonna
have to commit civil disobedience
we're gonna have to stop the machinery
of government the machinery of war it
would make sense to stop paying taxes
wouldn't it I mean you know I you know I
I hate saying that especially you know
with President Cheney watching
television everything you know but but
but you know it does I mean all these
taxes that don't go to support us and do
go to killing you know I mean I'm really
I mean like the war is bad for us but
isn't that nearly as bad for us as those
people in it running man I mean my god
yeah I think of how those people live
you know and that's not even the worst
place in the world I mean there's a lot
worse place thousands of children die
every day from bad water and you know
yeah not even Gore talks about that you
know it's it's it's a it's a really it's
a it's a very it's it's really
problematic but but there's but there's
another thing and I know like you're a
historian but being a historian you have
predictive powers right because the more
you know about what's happened the more
you can at least hopefully think about
the future not exactly but in ways it
seems to me that what we're doing with
Iran right now is crazy even if I
accepted the terms of President Cheney
that he's saying well they're making
like nuclear weapons and because they're
making nuclear weapons we're gonna have
to attack them and blow them up mmm now
that watch it kind of made sense in 1950
you know what I mean in the 20th century
in the 21st century even a tiny little
country like Luxembourg can make weapons
of mass destruction you know you don't
need a nuclear weapon you just get
adjourn it could be like in this tiny
little you can't see it just like well
you bring the charm over you know you
will beYOU know you wanna be a like a
suicide terrorist bring the germ over
now we could wipe out Baltimore you know
you know I mean it's like we need to
make peace because the way that we've
done our international relations does
kind of you know blowing up people it's
not gonna work anymore
well it's obviously it's not working in
Iraq right it isn't working in
Afghanistan we need to become a
different kind of country man we need to
stop
war-making country we need to stop
having military bases all over the world
we need to stop sending spending 500 600
billion dollars a year on war and I mean
they think what we could do with the
wealth of this country if we could draw
that wealth from two things from the
military budget and from the wealth of
the super-rich who've been getting
richer and richer and richer because of
the tax system and because of the
military contracts that they get so this
is a this is a very rich country we
could take care of our people here we
could take care and help people abroad
but we need a new social movement in
this country we need a movement which
will combine the energy of the labor
movement of of the 30s on a civil rights
movement of the 60s and the women's
movement of this 70s that we need a new
social movement and we have the basis
for it because people are learning
they're just not organized yet you know
and it's a matter of taking the new
understanding that people are getting
and beginning to organize all over the
country and creating a new social
movement because we're not going to be
able to write it we're not going to be
able to depend on whoever is president
in the White House even if we get a
better president in the White House we
could get a worse one
no we couldn't get worse so I mean it
has to be better definitely have a
better one but it has to be well we can
have a water enough we'd have a better
president that we just had a lottery in
this room and right we'd have a better
president there's no question of a
lottery out on the street you just throw
like a yeah exactly a penny whoever gets
in your head with it but we don't need a
new social movement in this country and
because that's the only way we're gonna
bring about change and in order to have
a new social movement we need to people
need to become aware of the history of
social movements because they have
people have to become aware of their own
power people feel powerless and people
have to become aware and this is where
history comes in handy this really the
labor movement of the of the
anti-slavery movement people become
aware that it is possible for ordinary
people when they organize
in large enough numbers to change
history we don't have to depend on
Congress and the president of the
Supreme Court depend on ourselves then
historically when you see that has
happened in the past then you learn that
you can do it in the present so you know
we have a lot of work to do
yeah well we've been right I mean it's
one it's interesting thing how white
America begins to reflect black America
which I which I find so interesting here
because you know we were robbed of our
history from the get-go right they
brought us over on the boats they said
okay everybody who speaks a different
language will go you know will will
separate them all out so nobody can talk
to each other they can plot and
everything like that and now that's been
done to everybody in America all of
America has been robbed of their history
they don't know their history you know
and at least and at least we know we
don't know our history other people
think they know a history which is fake
you know it's it's it's not a true
history which I think it's one of the
great things about you know a wonderful
historian like you who wants to talk not
about the rich man's history not about
the generals history but the history of
the people who who either made changes
or or suffered the changes but you think
we should like answer some questions
from the audience
oh yeah you think yeah all right has to
go back but we just realized we have an
audience and and you deserve the right
to speak up right if you want to ask a
question there's a microphone over there
I think is that right T how do you spell
team
Thank You Howard lots of fun to talk to
you I'm going to attack you
and I'm definitely gonna come up to
Boston and visit will you yeah I'll be
great how are you hello
you spoke on a couple of topics that
touched me but most of the people in
this country are not aware of the how
the World Bank sends in economic hitmen
to take over other countries they want
their countries to fail would you
address that please yes sir thank you
Walter is very generous turning over
these tough questions to me yeah you
know the World Bank the International
you know Monetary Fund these these great
world financial institutions have been
dominated by the rich powers especially
by the United States and and they have
therefore used their power over money
and use their power over the poor
countries of the world to really distort
the economies of these countries and
basically to keep them poor and then to
add to their debt giving them being
willing to give them money for certain
reasons but not for other reasons so
what's happening however this is
encouraging that there's some places in
the world that the beginning to defy the
World Bank and the IMF the International
Monetary and to defy them you know I'm
thinking of these countries in Latin
America you know which are freeing
themselves from the control of the big
financial institutions dominated by the
United States you know I mean Venezuela
is an example then as well as in the
position and do it because they have
almost oil but I think this is going to
happen more and more and more and more
poor countries are going to find ways to
escape the power of the World Bank and
the IMF and know this this will mean
more economic democracy in the world and
part of that campaign worldwide is for
the American people to learn more about
how the United States the World Bank the
International Monetary Fund are keeping
people poor around the world and how we
have to play our part in changing our
own economic structure and our own
economic system so that the United
States no longer plays the kind of
exploiting role that it has played in
the world so we have a certain role to
play in helping people in other
countries and just want one common-sense
addendum very small one that you know a
the one of the reasons I I began to
understand that I that I was wasn't a
part of any system is because you know
my people live was will say things like
forgive Africa's debt the Conservatives
don't say it
they don't forgive it and we say forgive
it but I say what debt how could Africa
OS anything I say we've given them
billions we've stolen you know being an
American and and and you know and
identifying with with the Middle East
and with Europe hundreds of trillions of
dollars in natural resources and bodies
today you can't have yourself one won't
work if wasn't for Congo you know seven
million people have died in Congo in the
last ten years it's like it's like this
kind of crazy thing like forgive we owe
them you know it's it's another way of
saying you know with your talk about it
we owe them they don't owe us anything
yeah hi I'm this question is for either
of you gentlemen 40% of Americans
consider
selves to be independent ie not
registered or aligned with any of the
two major parties because they're fed up
with the corruption of the two-party
system so I wanted you to speak to that
and how you think independence can play
a role in this movement that we need
sorry because I don't want hard to think
I gave another tough question or maybe
you think that's nice I but I am like I
am starting this organization I was a
little I am starting an organization I
hope to call it democracy initiatives
we'll see you know if there's another
organization named that but but I hope
to call it that what I would like to do
is I don't want a third party I want
Americans to fragment and then come
together after they fragments of what
you do is you you find your own interest
you find your own interest group you
find out what you want to do you come
together with those people and you learn
how to put pressure on the powers that
be with whatever level of voting and
other political powers that you've
garnered through getting together I want
to use all of them I want to stop the
Republicans in the Democrats because
they don't represent democracy they
represent oligarchy but I but I don't
want to be fooled by a third party
because you know third party you just
buy that party to you know say well damn
oh yeah there's more than enough money
to go around with you five hundred
billion yeah no more enough to give to
you know to them two'll if they if they
want to join in the game but I don't I
don't want that and I want well the 40%
of Americans are unaligned they are not
in a party yeah yeah that's right that's
what I mean but but but i but you know I
wouldn't want it you know one of the
things when somebody said well let's
start a party that gets those forty
percent cuz thinking that maybe they
were thinking sensibly but what but I
want to do it I want people to actually
form into many smaller groups you know I
would love to democratize the House of
Representatives to overthrow them to
make sure that neither the Democrats or
the Republicans had more than 49 percent
of the vote and that would mean that
they would have to really talk about
some stuff in there you know they
wouldn't have to say oh no no man you
got to convince me and you know I come
from you know Utah and it's hard they
convinced me you know I whatever
whatever the people are gonna say but
but but to have it not to think of a
third party I know you didn't say third
party but I just want to be very clear
to say I don't want you know Ralph Nader
I like him but I don't want
Nader you know because you know his the
people underneath him will get bought
out too anybody can get bought out with
the amount of money they have and the
amount of power they have well Walter
can I say something well no I think it's
useful to have a third party somebody
like Ralph Nader to say things that the
other parties won't say right to raise
issues that they won't raise to be
honest you know and and it can play
third parties can play a very useful
role that way cuz they're not gonna get
elected because our political system is
not a democratic one and how it's in
said that yeah and so the third party is
not going to get elected but the third
party can play you know a role but
ultimately and and this is where you
know I agree to Walter ultimately it
isn't a matter of who's in office it's a
matter of who's sitting outside the
office of who's sitting and who's
demonstrating even whites yeah it's a
matter of people power and because the
real issue is are we gonna have a
People's Movement in this country which
is going to arrest on the will of all of
those people who know that the two-party
system is corrupt who know that the
two-party system is not what we want all
these people people in this country
mobilize their energy and create a
social movement which as in the past
have pushed and pushed and pushed
Congress the president the Supreme Court
into doing what they didn't want to do
in the first place with it where ever we
have had any changes in a direction of
justice in this country have come not
from voting for this party or that party
but have come from the people themselves
and I mean that's a hard thing to grasp
because it's easier to go to polls every
to four years or four years and vote and
they want us to think that that's the
way
it's harder to work everyday to organize
and build grassroots movements that will
finally create a national movement which
will bring about change it's one more
question okay good afternoon
my questions for you mr. Zinn in regards
to social movements and specifically who
and when maybe as a young person it's
naive of me to seek answers to such a
big question but where are these new
pockets of leadership not even
leadership but leadership's
where are these groups of people is that
a corn workers organizing poultry
workers in Mississippi is it you know
public school teachers and our urban
schools is it educated young
professionals trying to go into the
political sphere it's easy to say you
know this is the way we should do it but
I want to know how and I'm bursting
because I really want to know and
hopefully you can Howard I know she says
use this question and I'm gonna let you
answer but I just wanna say I just to
throw one in Harry Belafonte has a group
called The Gathering where he's had I
think a dozen meetings of young
political activists around the country
its culminating in a very large meeting
in Oakland in the middle of September I
don't know exactly where but if you
googled the gathering you could find it
where that that this is definitely a
group of people who are moving you know
and it's also definitely a group of
young people working like kind of under
the umbrella of Belafonte but these are
people actually doing their own
political organizing and that would be a
good one to to follow our but you know
Walter there are a lot of there are a
lot of grassroots initiatives just like
Harry Belafonte's that had taken place
around the country Marian Wright Edelman
of the Children's Defense Fund
she has been organizing bringing young
black people from all over the country
to the Alex Haley Center in Tennessee
there are things happening all over the
country that people don't know about and
the problem is for people to know what
people are elsewhere are doing and for
them to begin to coordinate there are
thousands of groups in this country that
are doing things that nobody else knows
about and the problem is to get to know
about one another to make connections
with one another in order to build the
kind of national movement we need thank
you very much for coming we have to go